welcome everybody my name is Franz Rosen
and I will talk about attacking modern
web technologies when I wrote this talk
and I wrote the title of this talk this
word modern was intentional so the whole
idea with modern is basically some stuff
that people use right so instead of
talking about like the newest things
that nobody is using yet I will start to
focusing more on technologies that has
gained momentum so I will try to focus
on those I I won't try to talk about the
things you've been always hearing about
like sequel injections or or regular
vulnerabilities I will try to like find
another angle to it and I hope you're
gonna like that
my name is France I work as a security
adviser on a company called Detective
fight I do a lot of bug bounties it's
anybody here does anybody know what bug
bounties is raise your hand oh wow I did
this two years ago here and they were
like two people so 2016 I talked on a
dev as well I do a lot of blog posts on
on our labs blog about vulnerabilities
that I found or trying to look at and
try to dissect them and try to figure
out new things and new ways to do stuff
I do a lot of live hacking there's a
thing now called life hacking where you
basically go to an event you get like
you travel well delay you travel to a
bunch of cities and you hack a bunch of
companies and you can win prizes you win
money of course but you also win like a
boxing belt so I've been trying to do
that for almost a year
and I won't a boxing belt last year in
Vegas and I won a boxing belt two months
ago in Montreal which was awesome today
I will talk about three things but it's
gonna be a lot of information so I hope
you're gonna be like excited about it
it's a bit technical and I'll try to
explain as good as good as possible
I'll talk about app cache app cache is
not really something modern but I will
talk about how you can apply it to stuff
that has been used today it's a legacy
feature in all the browsers and there
was a
they're in all of them upload policies
which is one way to actually work with
files nowadays and a deep dive in
postmessage it's gonna be most of the
details in this talk it's gonna be a
round post message so appcache as I said
not modern modern and old and the
vulnerability I'm gonna talk about here
a disclaimer first was found
independently by another guy a genius
guy from Hong Kong called file
descriptor and he also talked about it
on last epic Europe last year so I'm
gonna talk about first what app Cash's
app cache is well this one is I'm gonna
do this is that app josh is basically a
way to cache files on your website so
whenever you go to your website you can
have a manifest attribute in the HTML
whenever you have that your browser will
download that file and if that file
contains a cache manifest it will
actually fetch those files as well in
this in this cache file and then
depending on the rules in the manifest
will serve these files instead of the
ones being online so we will actually
save a local version of these files now
in the specification of app cache there
is something called fall back fall back
means that if the browser is unable to
fetch any file in the directory you
specified it will instead download the
fall back and use that one so that means
if you unplug your your this is not how
you unplug your Wi-Fi but if you unplug
your internet for example and go offline
you can still surf your the website
because it will use the app cache
because you can't connect to the website
the interesting thing though with
fallback was that you you would like
presume that if you're actually offline
it will serve the fallback but it turns
out if it gets a specific amount of
status codes of the website as well such
as error 500 error 500 is commonly used
for like when your website server is
overloaded or
like if something failed in the
communication with the web server so you
can argue that kind of makes sense
having the fallback serve to fall back
on in case of 500 error what we also
found out is that how can you trigger by
intention on a website of 500 error
there is a classic thing called cookie
stuffing cookie stuffing is basically
filling using JavaScript your cookie jar
in your browser with a bunch of cookies
meaning that whenever the person that
got affected by the cookie stuffing
visits the website it will send a huge
amount of of cookies in the header so
that means that the website will
actually error 500 because it's like
whoa wait a minute this is too much of a
header to actually handle now the bug in
this combining these two things this
fallback thing with this cookie stuffing
was that if you had a website under a
path like you could have in this case we
have like you as in user and then you
had an ID for the user ID and then a
manifest inside this this directory and
this manifest
in this like child directory also said
fallback
slash meaning anything on this website
should use this fallback URL instead at
the same time installing the cookie
stuffer you could make it serve on any
page on this website and this kind of
like this user path was a security
boundary in this website's example this
example is actually from Dropbox and I
will show you actually how that worked
so the reason why this bug existed the
bug that existed was basically like you
could use a fallback for everything even
though you had a manifest inside a child
path you should not be able to escape
your directory and affect the whole
website with this manifest so looking at
the specification they said basically
manifest can only specify fall backs
that are in the same path as the
manifest itself this specification sucks
because it means basically like ok does
that mean that the fall
back needs to be next to the to the to
the manifest is that that what it was
like that's not really the problem here
the problem here is you could have a
little file a manifest inside a path and
then effect the whole website anything
on it if you're working with with Amazon
s3 buckets anyone recognizes three
buckets raise your hand you know that
they have two ways of like accessing the
bucket they could have a subdomain and
also a user path that means if you can
install a manifest on an s3 bucket you
can affect any s3 bucket using the path
which is terrible so I'm gonna show you
a demo it's a bit light and it's a bit
bright in here but I will try to explain
what's happening here
so Dropbox had a user content sandbox
domain and this Dropbox user content you
could actually in the past you could
serve HTML files there they deprecated
that because why would you need to serve
HTML web sites on our Dropbox domain
however they forgot that XML files can
act as an HTML by enabling specific
XHTML namespaces so they served an
inline XML I made it into an HTML so we
could actually run JavaScript I also
point to the manifest from this file and
if you look closely you will see that
this is the user path I'm talking about
so I'm in a user path another user would
have a totally different path and we
should not be able to talk to each other
or at least affect each other the thing
is whenever you go into this website it
will install the manifest and it'll also
install the cookie bomb meaning that any
URL you will visit after my manifest
will use my fallback file my fallback
file will load an external image using
javascript and leaking the URL that
you're trying to access so what happens
is that when you go to a drop box a
regular day going to drop box comm and
you click download you go to drop box
User Content drop downloading that file
but when you have my manifest installed
with which
not expire it will leak the URL to me
and send me the secret URL you have the
signed URL and leave the file which is
terrible because you can't really like
you need to wipe your cache completely
you can't just it doesn't expire at all
so I'm gonna show what happens here I
will go to the manifest and you will see
there that it's actually installing the
manifest and you can look in the console
it would say like I'm downloading the
manifest I have the fallback everything
and now whenever I go to any file I will
actually alert it as well and now if I
go to a Dropbox file and take oh I want
to download this file this is a secret
file shared between me and my friend
this one will actually like I will take
the URL and I will also go to my
external leaking page leaking the file
that I can just download myself so
whenever when I sent this to or me and
Matias we were two people finding this
we sent it to Dropbox they were like oh
[ __ ] like this is this is this is not a
browser specific thing every browser did
it wrong every browser and now I talking
Safari Chrome Firefox and Internet
Explorer and edge so when they saw this
they were like okay we need to remove
this Dropbox user content completely
yeah the whole bug was basically these
these specific ones you could run on XML
as HTML on their Dropbox User Content
you could install a manifest using an
XML you could like any file that you
would download would trigger this and
also make this JavaScript run and every
secret link would believe to that hacker
they paid us twelve thousand dollars
worth twelve thousand eight hundred
dollars to baeksang also what happened
was that Dropbox is so awesome when it
comes to security they actually had
started to deprecated a bunch of stuff
first they said like no XML HTML and
we're gonna like deprecated the Dropbox
public directory completely you're not
able to serve any files there they
helped us talking with all the browser
vendors also the browser vendors fixed
this so you're not able to escape your
user path and install the manifest
across the whole domain
also everybody's trying to get rid of
this appcache thing because there's a
new thing called serviceworkers which is
a bit more specified in terms of
security boundaries and and how to
actually they have like an expiry date
app cache does not also Dropbox
installed
random subdomains so even if we were
able to install a manifest on one
subdomain they have random domains all
over the place they have a wild-card
pointing to their router the browser
paid us bounties as well for this
because they realized like hey this is
this is really bad the interesting thing
is that like the fix that they did was
basically to be able to escape your home
your own path so whenever you find a
file upload somewhere that is served by
HTTPS where you can upload HTML files
like this is not unlikely scenario
nowadays because nowadays people as
Dropbox did put their content on our
sandbox domain sandbox domain the
concept of sandbox domain is interesting
because as soon as you starting using a
sandbox you kind of like to have a
sandbox like you can put all the [ __ ]
over there but then accidentally you
might realize that you actually hire the
privileged of your sandbox domain and I
will show an example of that and also
the thing that you can now do is that
whenever you can upload files in the
same directory as other users you can
still do this thing so this was only to
like escaping the scaping was the bug
but that cache this is how app cache
should work also serviceworkers exists
they they have some higher boundaries to
actually be installed such as like you
actually need a header of the instead of
just having a manifest which is a text
file you actually need to have installed
the the serviceworker with a specific
header that finally is respond with a
specific header so but it's still very
interesting we're looking at file
uploads to actually look at this because
you can still abuse this very much so
talking about file uploads this is
basically something I really searching
last year but I've been trying to like
get some of those stuff out there like
some of the issues that have
see so upload pollicis is basically a
way to isolate your file uploads from
your web server that means that back in
the days you basically had a file upload
and those files were stored at your
server and you just had to cross your
fingers hoping that nobody uploaded like
a PHP file or a dotnet or VB or whatever
to actually take over your whole server
so whenever this thing came up where you
can have like a bottomless storage of
files you don't need to think about like
like disk is full or whatever you can
just have a bottomless hole of full of
files people starting using that now the
first way people starting using it was
basically to whenever someone uploads
the file the file reaches your server
and then you send it forward like you
paid forward and send it over to the
storage however these upload policies or
these bucket providers as a cloud
platform or AWS they realized like can't
we do something that allows the user to
upload directly to the bucket so and
they realized that oh this is a smart
idea so the whole concept of this is
basically like fast secure and easier to
do wrong unfortunately it looks like
this basically what the whole concept is
the the person that develops or owns
this bucket writes a policy this policy
is the rule set of how you're able to
upload files to this bucket the owner
then signs the policy with a with a
secret and when the user uploads a file
it uploads it together with the policy
and with the signature and the what will
happen on the other side is that AWS
will verify that the it was signed
properly with the secret key and that
the upload is following the policy the
policy is still in the bottom it's
actually like a basics before encoded
JSON it looks like this every row on
this JSON or in this policy can affect
you in a really bad way so if you look
at the concept of this this has a bunch
of
conditions or restrictions the first
restriction says it should only be able
to upload files to the example uploads
the key which is the file name of the
order and the URL that it will end up to
should start with a specific year not a
path in this case but a specific prefix
the access control layer should be like
public public read and whenever you
successfully upload something it should
redirect the content type should start
with nothing so that qualifies every
time and then you have the content
length range like this is the allowed
size of stuff that's gonna be uploaded
so the first thing that you can do wrong
is that you have starts with key does
not contain a path separator remember
the thing we talked about just now the
service workers in the app cache if
people are uploading stuff to the same
path you were able to do this like
hijacking of like listening to other
people's files when they access them
also when starts with key doesn't
contain anything we have a really bad
problem because that means that you can
override any file in the bucket so
whenever you know someone else's file
and the policy says please start with
whatever you want you can just use that
key that they use and override their
file and you can also make it empty or
like so you're basically able to delete
or modify other people's files other
example is when content type starts with
nothing that means that we can upload
HTML files as I said like this might be
a sandbox domain so an XSS doesn't
necessarily mean something however
people would probably download stuff
from the sandbox domain so installing
this app cache might be still a
vulnerability that they want to know
about know also what's interesting is
that it doesn't have even matter that
the start switch is empty it could be
starts with image slash JPEG because
certain browsers such as Chrome getting
image JPEGs semi semi colon text HTML it
was just like oh I don't know how to
parse JPEGs
I will actually use text HTML and then
will serve it as a text HTML so this is
completely pointless having starts with
with a mime because you can just append
to it and it will break another form of
like policy uploads is called a WS STS
which is like a token service as like a
security token service and what what is
or temporary so tokens are I'm sorry
what it does is basically generates real
AWS keys to the client using of policy
as well this is like super dangerous
like it you should really know what
you're doing if you're gonna use this
service because every time I've seen
this people have put their access
control of the tokens you get as like
yeah you can access whatever server you
want in our AWS account which is
terrible so the whole idea is basically
you post to the STS a Amazon AWS with a
sign policy and then you get back like
access keys that you can actually use in
your command line or by the browser or
whatever and then you can just like
insert them into your AWS CLI and just
query everything one of these examples
was basically exactly like this like
they had s3 star and you could access
all the code modify older code upload
new code they had a whole code pipeline
air in those s3 buckets another example
is Google cloud works exactly the same
way as AWS it's just different wording
but this flow was basically a custom
flow built by a website so they had
whenever you wanted to download a file
they made a request or no upload a file
you wanted to upload a file they made a
request to their own website and that
website returned back a signed URL to
storage Google api's and this means
means that this URL was allowed to
actually post to so you could post
whatever to it and it would replace the
file content but as you see in there in
the upper JSON we could select whatever
file we want and also like we can also
sign every URL we want so if we know
that there's a file named specifically
something we can just insert that name
and in this case they would create a
signed URL that works both for reading
and writing so you could just take that
URL and read it and you could select
whatever file you want it
in this case they had everything in that
one and everything was predictable
because they had an America invoices so
they obviously paid a lot of money for
that vulnerability and the whole core
idea here is that the writing your own
policy logic is the worst like it's so
hard to do right and talking about
policy logic
it's like policy logic means that you
get something from the user and you
create a signed link out of the thing
that they gave gave you and you give
back a signed link that's the policy
logic I'm talking around here so
basically the user get to pick something
and then you create a signed link based
on that terrible idea
sign links should not be used to control
they should always be like randomly used
like randomly generated by you and
that's that's that's the way to do it
basically so the goal is to reach the
route okay so whenever we want to abuse
policy logic we want to reach the route
of the bucket because what happens in
the route of the bucket is that if
you're able to create a signed link to
the like the parent directory of the
whole bucket you can create a file
listing out of that Bay it's a little
bit based on your iam policies or like
access policies but the the standard
functionality is you will get a file
listing that means that you don't even
need to figure out what the files of
other users are you can just see them
all over the place one example that was
like bringing back the back to 99 when
you did like file or path traversal
using dot slash was basically a website
where you could get an image and
whenever you gave it a key it will give
you a signed URL to that image but the
thing was what they did was if you did
like a key dot dot slash dot dot slash
dot dot slash it would normalize the URL
and then create a sign link out of that
so it actually had three paths for the
user but you just ripped like went out
of those paths it create assigned links
and you had file access to every object
and everything being in that in that
bucket basically another example was
like this so you had this is one of the
format's of s3 buckets and this
functionality of this website was if you
provided the the upper example they had
a regular expression to to move it into
the proper way of how they wanted the
sign links to work so if you had the
subdomain of the bucket it would move it
to being a path of this s3 and if you
have stuff afterward like a directory in
a file it would put it afterwards after
that so by giving them this they would
just like freak out and don't know
really what to do because they thought
it was like a subdomain of s3 but that
one is empty so they just gave you find
bucket root folder which also gave you
access to every object and every listing
my favorite logic of this or my favorite
example of this was looks like this so
basically you upload a file what
happened then is that it would generate
a random name for you but you would
actually select the random name yourself
like your your browser would generate a
random value and it would send it to the
server so you could just control it it
was actually called random key so
whatever you sent into the random key
would point to the one called esta aqui
so I said s3 key / please and xx 11 for
random key it would say okay cool I have
random key X x11 and s3 ki slash that
means that you could go to secure
example.com slash file slash X X 11 and
that we will sign it for you and you
went to it and it would sign of the
bucket it would sign the slash and you
had full read access to every object in
the directory also like whenever you
know where a file is you can just
provide them with that file name instead
and you will get the sign URL to
download that file which is terrible so
I've been doing this for a while and
I'll be reporting it to a bunch of
companies and a lot of people are
exposing huge amount of data and and
this is like not directly compared to
like people have actually had public
buckets open it has been like the knee
in the news for the late
year where people had like voting
records online or they had a bunch of
user data online like this is not they
are actually having a proper access
model looking from the bucket
perspective but their business logic of
their website is just breaking that
apart completely one of the best
examples I had was when a company
realized that they affected everything
they had and they had everything in one
bucket and I tried to make the finalist
thing to show them how big it was but I
couldn't because it was too big so they
had a bunch I came to around 2 gigabytes
of file listing until I like ok I need
to tell you about this all right last
topic I'm going fast here but this is
because this is my favorite subject
so deep-diving post message what is post
message post message is away for 2
windows in your browser to talk with
each other that's the like the easiest
way to to to explain it to win those two
tabs whatever they can communicate with
each other even though they're like it
could be New York Times and Washington
Post they could still communicate with
each other it's also emphasizing being
safely which is like I would not agree
on that what I did in the last year is
that I realized that post message is
something that has got gone gaining so
much traction because it's an easy way
to like work across website talk with
the browser website you can create a
gadget or a widget cross-domain like it
enables cross communication cross-origin
communication so it's awesome for small
little startups doing a gadget in in a
like a customer service widget that you
install on your website or a check out
on your newer ecommerce so I realized
that the the tools were lacking for
actually working with postmessage so I
wrote the Chrome extension called post
message tracker and what it does is
basically two things first thing is that
it will listen to all the messages being
sent between windows and the and iframes
and everything and it will show you the
content of these messages in the console
what it will also do is that it will
have a little icon in your browser
defining how many listeners you have
because the listeners are the ones being
interesting here it doesn't matter if
you're sending a message if someone is
not listening to that message and the
listeners are the ones being vulnerable
for a bunch of things and one of those
classic examples of a vulnerability in
post message is whenever you don't
validate where the message came from you
need to do this yourself
whenever you get a message you need to
like okay alright who is it that sends
me this message this is up to you
there's no helper there's nothing in the
browser that helps you to do this easily
which is one of the reasons that this is
just a terrible environment right now to
be in when it comes to looking for
security issues or like if if you're
like me it's like pretty awesome because
you find a lot of weird cases one of the
examples this is a really good example
whenever this website gets a message and
that message is adjacent with the
property evil call it will just take the
message and put it into the eval
function and you could do like you can
run whatever JavaScript you want so
opening this website from another
website you create a relation between
these websites and you send that window
a post message saying like alert or
whatever and that will work because it
says oh I don't care about who's sending
me there's this message I will actually
just take your data and use it in my
JavaScript function so that's also what
the extension is doing is basically
showing you the functions that is being
used for talking with or showing the
function of the listener another example
is this is like a regular Java like an
XSS case basically if it gets a JSON
with the property j j s load script like
that's a terrible indication that
something is wrong here and that type is
iframe it will try to create an iframe
element with whatever you want if it's
not an iframe it will actually just take
the value and load the script and in
inject the script into it so just
sending that window a value that takes
JavaScript
will trigger that JavaScript so going to
the more interesting ones because
postmessage turns out to be like a
really used thing for third parties so
whenever you have a website having
Google tag manager on and the marketing
team loves injecting a bunch of
affiliates pixels or whatever turns out
there's a lot of listeners being
included there one of these example was
one called click tail click tail is can
someone see the problem with this I'm
I'm so like I'm talking so fast people
like what there's some vulnerability
here yeah there is so the problem here
is that this is a regular expression
trying to figure out who's sending the
message the problem is that a regular
expression the dot in a regular
expression means any character so if you
don't escape the dots that means that
you can just like buy a new website
called app X click tail comm or whatever
you want instead of the X you can buy
that website and the origin will be
allowed so any any character works when
docked is not escaped in our regular
expression which is really common
mistake now looking at this listener III
knew I knew from the fact that I could
bypass it I knew that I could like talk
with it because I saw the vulnerable
origin check but I didn't know what I
could actually do so I saw this and I'm
like okay it doesn't do it create rules
like what the hell is that I don't know
and I looked at rules and I realized
that the rule contained of three things
action state and a trigger and I was
like okay this seems deep I have no idea
what it does I looked at the action
rules and what it does was basically
creating a bunch of events and then
triggered a bunch of things so I started
looking deeper in the function or in the
in the functions being here and I
realized that you can extract things
from the window and I saw for example
like the cookie value was super
interesting the jas variable very was
super interesting and also the element
value was super interesting but the
thing is you had to have a trigger and a
state and an action so the trigger I
realized just have a delay of five
seconds that's that's the way to build
up the trigger
just wanted to pass every time the state
I wanted to trigger whenever it is on
the domain I want to attack so I know
for a fact that I'm opening another
window pointing to the the company using
this so I will just provide the domain
of the company using clique tail and I
will give them like if the J is variable
of the clique tail cookie domain is
example com
please do this action and the action I
did was basically taking the cookie
value the C surf talkin and also getting
the value of the whole website the
seesaw is C surf token is basically like
the the the way people mitigate to
submit forms as the user so if you have
that one your probably most likely able
to make a post request to the website
the website thinks you are the user
actually and and you're able to do
whatever modifications you want
so my proof of concept was basically
whenever you go to my website and opens
up another link to this website I will
run this post message sending over all
the rules that I want to tell tell it to
trigger it should delay on five seconds
and if it's on this domain please run
and then please give me back the C surf
talkin and the Dom and it will just give
me the system token and all the HTML
which was super interesting because it
took a lot of time actually reversing
that JavaScript another thing and I
talked about this before is that the
like the sandbox domain the isolated
domains right sandbox domain is like
something you can just throw a lot of
things on because it's not trusted you
don't care about it however this case
was a company that really utilizes
sandbox domains or isolated domains but
what they did was also to utilize it for
other things such as they had a word
document uploader and they realized that
parsing word is scary like you don't
want to do that server-side so they
found a library that converted a word
file client-side by JavaScript into HTML
or markdown in this case but they didn't
want to run that third-party JavaScript
on their main domain because it might
have issues it's a really complicated
thing trying to extract
date out of a word file so what they did
was they use their sandbox so whenever
you upload a file a word file it will
send it down to the sandbox the sandbox
will run this word converter and then
return back at the markdown as a base64
encoded string now this was the sandbox
that they didn't really care about they
thought so it was easy to find an XSS on
the user sandbox and it would be if you
would tell them like you have an XSS in
the sandbox they were like yeah it's a
sandbox we don't really care however
what I did to show them that they should
care was that basically having an XSS on
user sandbox if someone goes to my URL
that I sent to them and they open up the
regular website their their higher
privilege domain and then decides to
upload a word document that one will
open an iframe in this iframe it will
then convert that file but since we are
at the same origin as the first website
this website can actually reach into the
other frame down to the iframe modified
the JavaScript of the iframe meaning
whenever you upload the file and getting
passed through the iframe I can take it
over and send it over to my XSS website
where I got the content and can just
like send it over to a third party so
they realize okay we can't really do
that thing we need to think about the
sandbox being a real sandbox not in the
middle another thing I found was
client-side race conditions if you know
what race conditions is is basically
something when you stress a system so
much it will behave differently from if
you would not stress it so in this case
you had a localization like script that
was running on a website whenever you
went to the website it would figure out
what language you would use and then it
would use an iframe to load the
JavaScript with all the the meanings in
the proper language however as you see
the origin check here is doing something
a classic mistake called index of and
index of basically means that it would
just check if it begins with it so in
this case you checked for link comm but
you can just do link comm dot example
calm as
domaine and it will work now looking
after javascript that was loading
whenever the iframe was done you could
see two things these things was
basically a check to only run once
so whenever the iframe loaded it would
send a message over to the parent domain
and the first message that reached it
would load a javascript file with the
language data looking at this javascript
you would also see that the currency
field that was existing when sending a
message it wasn't escaped at all so you
could add your own parameters through
the URL that was loaded on the main
domain and looking at the URL it was
loaded being JavaScript I found that the
curt when the currency field is scared
not escaped you could attend attend your
own get parameter called OSL in this
case and you could inject your own
javascript in that JavaScript that was
served so you can serve whatever you
want now when I try this they were like
okay we're gonna block alert like this
is the most ridiculous code piece of
code that you can ever see because
blocking alerts is basically just like
that's not how you hack a website alert
is basically a proof of concept of
trying to show you that there's an issue
if you hide that one that's a terrible
idea and it's super easy to bypass you
just create a new iframe and then use
that iframes alert instead so it's super
super basic it's actually a really cool
challenge like remove the alert function
and try is the only way I've found to be
the working case of trying to bring back
alert because it's actually pretty hard
like getting it back now the proof of
concept of this was basically open link
calm example calm opening the website
and whenever it opens the website stress
it with a bunch of messages saying
please currency is now a new parameter
with my alert escaping function and then
trying to trigger the alert for real
whenever the website loads it loads
their JavaScript tries to load the
iframe but we were faster than the
iframe so we can actually trigger the
the XSS which was also yeah so the post
message between GS load an iframe load
worked in all browsers I think I can
manage to do the last one before time is
out multiple bugs this is like super
confusing one ok first bug here there's
two bugs in this code this is our
another client-side race condition the
first bug here is the replace function
classic mistake in JavaScript if you
don't have /g meaning global it will
replace the first bot so they had a
mitigation it just forgot to add /g to
the replace function so that means that
this means that the example dot Co the
dot there can be whatever they want the
other bug in this case is co dot n said
because 2015 and you seal and decided
that anybody could use short and z
domain names so that means that if we by
example our code NZ that origin will
pass and turns out that website is
available to buy so the example of the
vulnerable scenario was a website that
had food recommendations you could
subscribe to their service the service
was so big and so we're covering a lot
of things so they had a PCI certified
iframe with the credit card input
whenever it loaded the iframe it would
send an initiation a call to it the the
iframe would then allow that save the
the sender of the init as the old owner
of them of the message or anything they
will communicate back it will use that
source and then it would send back a
message to the source saying please
don't kill my iframe because the main
frame would kill thy frame if it didn't
respond in time now whenever does that
is done the the main frame will then say
okay please use this stripe key for the
payment and the iframe will say all
right then I will in inch initiate
stripe payment using this key did you
see the problem so so little time now
example Akko opens up I like food yeah I
like food opens the iframe because the
user want to subscribe we stress the
iframe sending a bunch of data and we're
a we're valid origin in this case
sending please use this key for payment
please use this key for payment and now
not using in it I'm using load what
happens is that the init dance will go
with together with the iframe and the
main website
but it will actually after the init is
done it will still listen to any load so
because we were faster on the second one
the loading thing we will actually get
to our stripe key into the iframe the
iframe will show the credit card input
with our stripe key when the user tries
to pay it will say payment failed going
into our attackers account we will get a
token using that token we can initiate
the payment using their their API and we
can capture the money so the post
message from open are between two like
we came in two to two different message
calls we came just in between those and
chrome seems to be the only guys doing
this wrong so or basing a lot wrong is
just you're able to actually inject in
the middle of the communication here's a
guy with a horse
I haven't released post message tracker
yet but I will hopefully do it thank you
very much Wow
[Applause]